the technology is fast moving
from next week testing for coronavirus
in the uk
will be easier than ever less invasive
with no need for a health professional
to administer them
5.8 million on the spot test will be
using dna
alongside 450 000 swap samples
and rather than the current one to two
day weight the results are known
within an hour and a half we can expand
testing capacity further
and into settings where for instance in
in schools we have a
currently we have survey testing so we
have some testing
that would be able to be expanded but
also looking at
looking across the community where we
want to test ace
people who don't have symptoms to find
out where the virus is
the testing system itself is complex and
reliant on multiple supply chains to
source the products
but it's hoped that it could open up a
new phase in mass testing
across the country these tests could
signify
a game-changing moment not only will
they be able to be carried out by
practically
anyone but they can also detect seasonal
flu
meanwhile those behind the testing say
that controls are being put in place
so as they can avoid any false negatives
britain had come under severe criticism
at the start of the pandemic
the government was blamed for being too
slow to go into lockdown
two lakhs and testing and had failed to
get a successful track and trace system
up and running and despite promising
leads in its bid to find a vaccine
recent regional surges in the uk and the
rest of europe
are a warning that the pandemic is
nowhere near over
there is no silver bullet at the moment
and there might never be for now
stopping out breaks comes down to the
basics of public health and disease
control
testing isolating and treating
patients and tracing and quarantining
their contacts
the message more or less the same as it
was at the start of the pandemic
the basic prevention measures are as
crucial as ever
as governments try to stamp out rising
infection rates
to avoid the full lockdowns that have
crippled economies
around the world sony gallego al jazeera
london